as if we needed more proof that not only
is the immigrant Caravan coming to the
United States not a threat but also that
even the Trump administration knows that
the immigrant Caravan is not a threat we
now have that proof when the immigrant
Caravan first got going the Pentagon as
it often does did an assessment and
informed the Trump administration that
this Caravan poses no threat to national
security it poses no threat to economic
security they explained that you've got
a caravan that is dwindling quickly that
a tiny portion of the people in the
caravan are even going to make it to the
us-mexico border at all and that the
people who show up will request asylum
and that this is simply not going to be
anything that is even going to remotely
potentially overwhelm law enforcement or
require the military to be down there
and Donald Trump and right-wingers have
been warning us about an invasion and
yet the documents that the Pentagon put
together that said there's no invasion
this is no threat several thousand
people have dwindled to 1500 as of last
Monday dwindled even more as of today
and likely will be a couple hundred who
will ultimately get here and legally
seek asylum the Trump administration had
that report when Trump decided that he's
going to send 5,000 troops down to the
border possibly against the law and what
I mean by that is that it's not legal to
use the military for domestic law
enforcement period and that's what it
seems like Donald Trump is doing by
sending the military down there so there
are sort of two issues here to talk
about and neither one of them is new
issue number one is that Trump appears
not to trust his generals and he has a
distrust of both his generals and the
intelligence community and the Pentagon
that is extraordinarily problematic and
that's not a new problem and I've talked
about it before secondly you know who is
talking about the caravan as an invasion
of the worst lowlife criminals possibly
even with middle
Turner's mixed in with Hispanics can you
imagine that
Fox News is talking about that so this
is in addition to just being Trump not
trusting the Pentagon and his generals
and the intelligence community it's
Trump ending up parroting the Fox News
narrative instead of paying attention to
the official briefings that he's getting
certainly forget about the idea of
reading the reports that he gets because
we know he doesn't read unless it's one
page mostly pictures really big font
gigantic margins and so in the end this
is more signaling to the white
supremacists and the white nationalists
and the anti-semites and the xenophobes
I was on this really great podcast
Moeller she wrote over the weekend I
think they published the episode either
late Sunday or early Monday and we
talked about this signaling that takes
place and we talked about how when you
recognize that the president can't just
say anything if you're a white
nationalist or a white supremacist to
placate you you understand the signals
that are being sent and when you look at
this story who cares that immigrants
documented and undocumented are less
likely to commit crimes than
american-born citizens this is an
invasion and the white nationalist and
all of those groups understand the
signal from Trump when he says it who
cares that undocumented immigrants
actually end up paying more into our
social welfare programs than they get
back out the narrative is these are lazy
leeches who were lazy but taking your
jobs which is an interesting
contradiction by the way the same people
that are coming here to be lazy and
leech off of welfare are coming here and
taking your jobs which is kind of a
ridiculous contradiction it doesn't
matter because the narrative is what
matters here and sadly it's not just the
troops that are militarizing the border
we are seeing the rise or I guess I
would say the return of these lunatic
militia members to the us-mexico border
and that's what I unfortunately have to
talk to you about next today's program
is made
possible in part by Indo Chino the
custom menswear line I went into the
Indo Chino Boston showroom I worked with
Chris I've had some bad suits in my day
and we were able to put something
together by taking a bunch of
measurements giving me advice about fit
and style I was able to pick colors and
fabrics and buttons and pockets and so
much else if you're not near a showroom
you can shop online at Indo Chino calm
enter your measurements and still get
all of those great customizations lapell
lining pockets buttons monogrammed and
then let the complements roll in when
you're photographed at that wedding that
you've got coming up and since November
is Black Friday season you can take
advantage of the lowest prices of the
year up to 70% off of everything go to
Indo Chino com use the code Pakman at
checkout to take advantage of Black
Friday pricing 70% off the regular
prices for made-to-measure suits
shipping is free Indo Chino kaam promo
code Pakman for up to 70% off amazing
deal for a made-to-measure suit and if
you're like me once you go custom you
don't go rack